Hello i'm henry cavill and i'm going to
break down a scene from the show The
Witcher shot-by-shot
where's Renfri?
she's at the tower with your little
friend right here Geralt is entered
Blaviken looking for someone called Renfri
or Shrike as you may know her from
the books if you're a fan of the books
her gang has been laying in wait for me
I'm blocking this stunt performers sword
below with nothing essentially we often
use cut-off swords for particularly
complex or technical pieces or pieces
which really very very dangerous this
sword is actually half length with the
half length it allows for a lot more
moves to be done which involve blood and
gore the difficulty is we all have to
perform like the sword is full-length
rather than half length when you're
moving at full speed and you're adrenaline
up and you're doing take off take
up to take sometimes that can be tricky
Now that geralt has walked through all
these menRenfri comes back into town
with Geralt's young friend marilka and
that was essentially her family and so
she decides to go to town and try and
take Geralt out.
If we cross swords. I won't be able to stop.
Emma Appleton who plays Renfri trained
relentlessly she trained for the full
believe it was three or four weeks she was in
there every day for hours on end
training with her team there was only so
much one can do to actually build up to
a fight which was this technical and so
I had the great fortune of working with
probably the best stunt performer I've
ever actually performed with and that
was was Lucy Cork her viper-like
actions were exactly what shrike or
Renfri is described like in the books
Our strikes were exact or at least
looked exact we were moving less than an
inch away from each other's heads she
had to move just enough and I had to
make sure that I was close enough so if
I was making a downward strike I have to
redirect my sword so it does end up
being less than an inch away from her
head when it misses it's a true dance
and requires a lot of patience and a lot of skill.
We're not so different!
Wolfgang and I really wanted to
make sure that the story was told
through the fight it's not just a random
fight of people swinging swords at each
other these are two people in a dance
and through that dance a story is told
Renfri was very much the aggressor
and Geralt is on the defensive
right up until
Within four moves she is completely defeated
and then Geralt stands back and gives
her the space he allows her one last
chance walk away from Blaviken and forget
and you won't be a monster and instead
As much as he hates the idea of it he's
not gonna lose his own life in the
process of someone who's determined to
die.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie!
toss a coin to your Witcher this is
going to be my deleted scenes and alternate
ending video for The Witcher Netflix
season 1 so if you're new to my channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos they're obviously in the middle
of shooting The Witcher Netflix season 2
they had to go on break briefly because
of the virus that's going on around the
world so I'll explain what's going on
with that at the end of the video and
how that's going to affect their release
date for The Witcher Netflix season 2
but we'll just break this down top 5
style careful for spoilers if you have
not seen The Witcher Netflix season 1
yet starting with number 5 the scene
that I put at the beginning of this
Geralt vs. Renfrew T in the butcher of
bladvic in episode 1 deleted scenes
there's a couple of things that they
changed during episode 1 a number of
different deleted scenes from very
different parts of the episode there was
originally a totally different actress
playing the maracas characters they
heavily reshot all of episode 1 there
were a couple different versions of the
two big fight scenes that they went
through even though there were multiple
big fight scenes during the episode like
you have the key camera that they open
episode 1 with most of the deleted
scenes that I'll cover will be just from
the butcher of blab ik in part of the
episode there were different versions of
Geralt versus Ren fries men with him
running the gauntlet and then Geralt
versus Renfri in that final fight like
Henry Cavill said in the original other
versions they didn't try to do it as one
take cutting it up a lot more but I
think they made the right call and
taking the extra time to do this first
fight the gauntlet run all in one take
the reason why they didn't do the Geralt
versus Renfri fight all in one take is
because they had to cut around the
actress who played Renfri for a couple
of the big moments during their fight
when they get particularly stabby they'd
have to switch in her stunt double for
that stuff then for the up-close shots
like this one here they cut swap in the
original actress for the more dramatic
moments but the regular actress here
still had to learn all the fight
choreography so she had to learn all
these moves even though the really
dangerous stuff was done by her stunt
double in Henry Cavill normally they
don't let the main actors do their own
stunts like this but Henry Cavill
actually demanded to do all of his own
stunts like this so all the sword
fighting is always him number 4 next big
deleted scene was also during The
Witcher
episode 1 there was a massive deleted
scene of Strega bore and renfro's
backstory that they full-on shot but
then decided to get rid of in the
editing Bay in favor of the exposition
with the illusions of the naked people
in the tower the big flesh parade in the
deleted scene they filmed all the curse
of the Black Sun backstory remember it's
meant to be the lesser of two evils
that's the name of the short story that
they borrowed from for this part of the
episode you would have seen Renfri's
mother the Queen agreeing to let
Stregobor experiment on and then get rid of
Renfri because she was born under an
eclipse so the whole idea with the
prophecy of the Black Sun is that a long
time ago a sorcerer prophesied that a
bunch of women who were born under
eclipses would eventually rise up and
gain demonic powers and in the world as
you saw during the series
Stregobor firmly believed this
prophecy so he would go around
experimenting on girls that were born
under eclipses trying to see if they
were marked by the curse of the Black
Sun the whole idea with that is that it
would show him as being just as terrible
as Renfri but they kind of tried to
explain that with her exposition in the
final version of the episode number
three there were a bunch of yennefer
deleted scenes that i just grouped
together here the first one they filmed
when yennefer was younger but had
already just become a sorceress she
meets a very young version of Tris who
had just arrived at ara tuza for
training to become a sorceress this is
the whole purpose of the scene was meant
to show how far yennefer had come since
she had arrived at ara tuza
and created a sense of mentorship
between yennefer in a very young version
of Tris they didn't really show you Tris
as time in training as a sorceress or
anything like that she just shows up at
the end as an adult and she has this
pre-existing relationship with yennefer
they've been friends for a long time the
other big yennefer deleted scene was
from the betrayer moon episode during
her graduation ceremony where she misses
it because she's going through that
really painful transformation and gives
up her fertility the scene was mostly
her talking to Fringila and Sabrina
later about how they felt about making
that sacrifice and how much it had
changed them they were trying to provide
a little more of a connection between
yennefer and Fringila before she'd
gone to nilfgaard before the big battle
of sodden hill because later she becomes
a much bigger character and a much more
important part of the story but you
don't have that much time between her
and yennefer early in the episode
number two there was another big deleted
scene between Geraldton mouse sack in
Episode seven it was originally supposed
to take place really early during
episode seven Geralt and mousesack fend
off and kill assassins sent by Queen
Calanthe the big change that they made for
the version that you saw in the show is
that Calanthe's assassins ended up being
ordinary sintra Knights rather than a
bunch of street thugs which in the
original version clan thiet hired to
take them down in the deleted scene
Geralt winds up killing them but on the
show he does not wind up killing the
guards there were also a couple moments
during this where Geralt threatens to
kill mouse sack thinking that he's in on
it with Queen Calanthe even though
mouse sack is his ally trying to help
him the number one  really big
deleted scene alternate ending for the
finale between Syria and Geralt so there
was a whole different version of this
ending scene where they're reunited the
showrunner says they filmed it all but
then cut it way down in the editing Bay
because they had cut out a bunch of
earlier scenes and potential meetings
between Geralt and Ciri in Brokilon
in the forest so when they finally
reunited in this ending scene the
Showrunner said that it felt like they
didn't earn all these moments during
this original version of the scene as
they filmed it so we'll just read from
this original script page this is the
way the scene originally went down
before they cut it all out Ciri walks up
to him and says you're here you're
really here shocked
Gerlat looks down at her you're alive
ciri says I've been looking for you I
was going to sodden and I didn't think
you'd ever find me Geralt mother's words
hit him this is what he was supposed to
do find he repeats her words people
linked by destiny will always find each
other ciri pulls back in surprise
locking eyes with the witcher and says
was my grandmother right am i your
destiny and in that instant Geralt knows
one thing he will never abandon this
child and says you're more than that
ciri much more serine odds and then
looks at him in the eye and says firmly
who is yennefer so as you can see in the
original version there's a much longer
exchange between the two of them they
seem much more familiar with each other
than it did in the final version but
because they could add a lot of earlier
scenes from earlier episodes and
potential meetings between the two of
them they didn't want them to feel quite
so familiar in this episode because
Geralt himself has never really
interacted with her as for what's going
on
with The Witcher Netflix season 2 I've
already done a couple videos so I'll
link those at the end of this originally
they hadn't planned on premiering season
2 until 2021 so honestly I don't think
that the delay is going to affect their
release date that much it's still going to
be out next year sometime I will be
doing more Witcher Netflix bonus videos
while we wait for season 2 to get here
so leave all your requests and your big
questions in the comments below
everyone click here for my new Witcher
Netflix season 2 teaser video and click
here for my new venom 2 carnage teaser
thank you so much for watching everyone
stays safe I'll see you guys tonight!